good evening thanks for joining us here
at five i'm denise feldes and i'm
christian cassadas breaking at five new
details and video from a deadly
officer-involved shooting that happened
this week marco mana is at metro
headquarters where he just spoke with
police leaders about this pretty
dramatic incident orco
well denise and christian this was a
very dynamic situation for metro police
they say that this started with the man
breaking into his ex-girlfriend's
apartment kidnapping her and then
dragging her outside at gunpoint to a
local supermarket near charleston and
sloan now this is new video released by
metro police just this afternoon you can
see the man identified as mario martinez
holding the woman and pointing his gun
at responding officers he tries to steal
multiple cars to drive away with her but
is not able to he then drags her through
a grocery store and is seen on
surveillance footage waving the gun
around once back outside police say
martinez pointed his gun at officers his
ex-girlfriend was able to get away from
him and that's when martinez and police
both exchanged gunfire we're told a
metro officer fired a rifle at martinez
multiple times martinez died at the
scene
it's really a nightmare scenario of a
mobile hostage situation
but thankfully
the citizen
that was kidnapped was not hurt the loss
of life obviously in any situation is
sad and tragic for the family members of
that person involved but in this
situation the suspect dictated the
actions of the officers and there was
little left for us to do
metro says if you're out in public and
you see a situation like this where
someone is being dragged at gunpoint you
should call police immediately now metro
police say that the woman did suffer
from minor injuries because martinez was
grabbing her and if martinez had
survived this incident he would have
faced multiple charges reporting live
tonight at metro headquarters orco mana
live local now